it's great to be joined today by Keith
Whittington who's a professor in the
Department of Politics at Princeton
University also author of the book speak
freely why universities must defend free
speech Keith this is a super interesting
topic to me and I've covered as this
pretty extensively and I've expressed
concerns about attempt to sort of limit
certain types of speech on campuses
about so-called safe spaces and trigger
warnings and whether that's doing a
service or disservice to college
students sort of in the context of the
real world that they'll eventually be
living in but I've also sort of
expressed concerned with how widespread
some claim this issue to be relative to
how widespread I believe it to be so to
sort of get us into the conversation
what's your primary concern with what
you observe happening on college and
university campuses right now sure well
I think it's clear there are some
problems I think it's unclear how this
has been a feature of campus life off
and on for a hundred years and so now
we're getting a lot of reporting about
speakers being shouted down there's
videos that go viral of it and so it's
much easier to see it when it happens
it's not completely evident that this is
a lot more common now than it was twenty
years ago for example but it's clearly a
problem and it's a problem indicative of
people being intolerant of views they
find offensive and disagreeable when
people come to campus um as we also saw
the other day with the professor of
Fresno State people off campus can be
very intolerant to views they are as
offensive that are being spoken on
campuses yeah and I feel like there's
this sort of never-ending sort of like
an infinite regression that takes place
whenever we talk about this where there
there seems to be sort of a fundamental
misunderstanding in some cases
particularly when it comes to these
college speaking tours that have become
very very in vogue among a lot of
political movements where on the one
hand if someone has been scheduled to
speak we should oppose sort of
violent protests or the physical
prevention of that person speaking in my
opinion but at the same time not
allowing someone to speak in the sense
that they're not going to be invited
that's by no means an infringement on
anyone's First Amendment rights or even
on free speech I would argue in other
words no one has a right to speak at any
college that they want to speak at so I
feel like the conversation often gets
very very muddled and the terms First
Amendment and free speech are very often
misused as well are you experiencing
that same thing oh for sure I think the
debate is often because these are
somewhat complex debates in part because
people aren't very clear I think you're
absolutely right that universities
should be thoughtful about who their
crema campus to talk to students and
some of the invitations are being
extended are being extended by faculty
administrators some invitations and
sprouts like it speakers are extended by
student groups in both cases people
really need to think about why they're
inviting campus what they're hoping to
accomplish by bringing them and
hopefully try to bring in people that
they think are interesting and helpful
and going to help campus conversation
but if they have the authority to bring
somebody in and they've made decisions
about who they ought to invite in we all
allow those people to speak everyone on
the campus has a right to I'm here from
people they think are going to be useful
and once they're there then it's
appropriate to argue that people made a
bad choice about who they brought in but
it's not appropriate to probably shut
them down and prevent them being able to
speak now at the same time it's
important to note that the speaker does
not get to have total immunity from the
consequences of the specific speech that
they plan to put out there right and and
that's where we then get to what is and
is not appropriate in terms of
counter-demonstrations certainly
demonstrations in principle are
protected by the First Amendment and
they should be encouraged and defended
to the extent that they're not breaking
any laws but how can we sort of open a
conversation about what that line is
because to say there can be
no consequences to the speaker or the
university to the speech that they are
inviting on campus would also be
problematic yeah I think that's right I
mean we should expect that there can be
demonstrations and protests when a
speaker comes to campus you certainly
expect that there'll be conversations on
campus beds being written other events
occurring they're all designed to
counter those each and and that's all
perfectly reasonable I think where we
have to toe the line is efforts to
prevent people from actually being able
to hear the speaker so efforts to block
access to the venue we've seen examples
of that kind of things such the audience
can't even get in here the speaker
efforts to shut down the speech once
it's occurred and forget the speech from
taking place those we really ought to
regard as off-limits but beyond that
it's perfectly reasonable to express
opposition and concerns about a
particular speaker who's come campus no
one should come on campus give a talk
and Dan expects they're not going to
receive criticism that their views are
so let me play devil's advocate with
that a little bit there is a common view
among some I won't even really
characterize who but it's it's sort of a
common view that speech and response to
speech is appropriate but that anything
physical in response to speech is not
appropriate and the counter-argument to
that would be sometimes the speech in it
self advocates real-world violence so as
an example if we bring someone to a
campus who is for example an
anti-semitic white supremacist who
believes effectively that Jews should be
done away with right and you know if you
could figure out what what that means
that even though it's just speech that
it is speech calling for real-world
violence action extermination whatever
and thus that it actually would be okay
to use
physical violence or physical means in
order to counter that speech what do you
think of that argument right I think we
ought to be very very cautious about
extending that kind of argument and I
think it's were
thinking hard if you're inviting people
to campus about the kind of person you
bring in campus and people who are
advocating violence might not be the
best choice for people agreeing to
campus precisely because there may be
better people making better arguments
that are more reasonable but the Supreme
Court has struggled over the course of
20 century to expand the ability of
people to express controversial views
and to express dissent and sometimes
that includes some people calling for
violence sometimes it's a violent
overthrow of government sometimes it's
violence against businesses sometimes
even violence against groups of people
and court I think correctly is in facade
is that if we're going to have a robust
debate about a wide-ranging set of ideas
we have to accept the fact that
sometimes people are going to advocate
for violent actions that where we have
draw the line has been actually inspire
to engage in violent actions but
threaten violent actions against
particular individuals
I think likewise on campus we should
draw that line the movie successful to
some people are going to come to campus
in fact many arguments that do hurt
violence and we should regard that's
acceptable how can we sort of get a
handle on how pervasive the problem is
on campuses and the reason I ask is you
mentioned at the beginning we don't
actually know whether this is more
prevalent now than 20 years ago we know
that it's certainly being discussed much
more and part of that I would argue is
because you have this sort of anti
social justice warrior free speech
warrior movement that has become very
very popular among particularly some
enclaves of the of the internet but is
it sort of like you know is cancer
actually more common or are people
living longer and thus alive long enough
to develop some kind of cancer but it's
not actually the cancer rate that's gone
up right it it seems like that's sort of
an analogy to what might be going on
here
I think these coming waves to some
degree and and how many of these
disrupted protests are occurring and
just invitations and
and I expect to eventually we'll sell
down a little bit I think some degree
were also recognizing how often this in
fact happens so the fact that they can
now draw attention to it has sort of
highlighted the fact this has always
been happening some campus problem and
we ought to recognize as a problem we
also don't want to overstate the degree
to which problem so it's it's also true
to the controversial speakers on campus
all the time I mean are able to give
speeches without any problems there are
faculty on campus and students on campus
who give controversial speeches all the
time without problem and so for the most
part campus beast works perfectly fine
but there are occasions when people
behave very badly and I think it's
importantly calling that out when it
happens and we try to explain what the
correct principles are to try to avoid
those instances happening again
going beyond just the speeches and the
protests of speeches what about in the
classroom I mean do you have a sense of
because that's another area where you
see some of these so-called free speech
warriors claim that there is a major
major growing problem which is that
dissenting ideas anything but sort of
progressive orthodoxy is just not
tolerated in the classroom by
departments by individual professors do
you have reason to believe that that's a
unique problem that's going on right now
a growing problem I don't know if it's a
growing problem I think it's a genuine
problem in some instances I think it's a
pervasive problem on the whole
undoubtedly there's some faculty who
probably did not behave as well as they
should and professionally as it should
in the classroom and students might feel
that any students are sometimes I'm
quick to make the assumption that
they're being treated unfairly because
that is when in fact faculty got
responsibility to probably guide
classroom discussions to take into
account not availing arguments to think
seriously about material in front of
them and students are sometimes
resistant to that because they find that
the arguments materials are being
confronted with are disagreeable and
students end they could their own views
and speech are being
because they have to do I'm actually
engaged with materials in the way that
we want to engage so it's sometimes hard
to tease out whether students are
correctly perceiving that they're being
frowned upon by faculty and other
students or whether they're mistreating
in the situation there is also a very
genuine problem in classrooms with
Vallabh self-censorship students very
nervous about how other students will
precede them and that results in some
students not speaking up as much as they
should not really giving voice to their
ideas because they're so worried about
what the reaction might be and we want
to encourage student be willing and
enabled speak up in class to put forward
arguments that sometimes are going to be
mistaken is I'm not going to be wrong
but it's important that we be able to
think it through and so we'll talk about
those things in classroom we all
recognize people we're going to
sometimes say things in the bathroom
that is mistaken offensive learn so to
the extent that you believe this to be a
problem what's the solution is it some
kind of department policy some kind of
academic fairness doctrine of sorts I
mean how is this something that you can
fix right so I think in part it's
important that university administrators
be on the same page about what free
speech principles are and then clear
that they're committed to them sometimes
I have policy consequences about what
exactly the regulations are you know
guiding the university and those need to
be stated clearly and they need to be
enforced
so students are disruptive of activities
on campus for example for administrators
need to be clear that's not acceptable
and they need to enforce those policies
I think it's also probably important to
help orient student when they arrive to
campus they should expect to encounter
there I think students often come into
college is not fully realizing that
these are going to be places or they're
gonna encounter disagreeable ideas where
ideas are hotly contested and far to
expect when they arrive on campus is
they're going to encounter things that
they find disturbing a man
sometimes offensive and that part of
what it means to go to college and
administrators ought to be trying
Perrigo students when they come in to
fully accept the kind of educational
process that they're embarking on so
they're not taken by surprise and so
they don't have to behave correctly when
they encounter particular episodes of
speech they're uncomfortable with the
book is speak freely why universities
must defend free speech we've been
speaking with the book's author
professor Keith Whittington Keith thank
you so much for talking to me about this
thank you very much appreciate it